espero que ya te haya dado una
suficiente intuición de lo que hay
detrás de la fórmula de la energía libre
de jeeps y en este vídeo lo que quiero
hacer es un poquito más riguroso y de
hecho quiero podría decir deducir la
fórmula así que para hacer eso vamos a
estudiar dos sistemas que tienen la
misma el mismo cambio la entropía y para
hacer eso vamos a usar nuestros bien
útiles diagramas tv
ok y lo que vamos a hacer es vamos a
tener dos sistemas uno que es
perfectamente reversible y otro que es
irreversible o espontáneo ok así que
ambos van a empezar en este punto de
aquí del diagrama pv bebé y van a llegar
a este otro punto y antes de que vayamos
exactamente a lo que están haciendo creo
que es bueno repasar de qué estamos
hablando con procesos reversibles e
irreversibles
ok um un proceso reversible es esta cosa
teórica donde no tienes fricción siempre
estás tan cerca al equilibrio que
siempre puedes regresar t aunque siempre
puedes regresar el sistema siempre
puedes ver como que la la reacción
siempre está moviéndose hacia la derecha
o hacia la izquierda no existe realmente
en la naturaleza pero es una
construcción teórica así que déjenme
dibujar este ejemplo
vamos a usar por ejemplo nuestros
también bastante conocidos pistones y
vamos a hacerlo dos veces uno va a ser
para los procesos reversibles y otro
para los ir
ok ahí están vamos a etiquetarlos
este de aquí va a ser el proceso
reversible y éste va a ser irreversible
aunque también podríamos considerarlo
como espontáneo
espontáneo muy bien esa es la palabra
clave lo que va a importar para la
energía libre de jeeps ok todas las
reacciones espontáneas son irreversibles
ahora vamos van a moverse de entre estos
dos puntos del diagrama vamos a poner
nuestro pequeño techo que va a ser el
pistón y ahí tenemos gas dentro
ejerciendo cierta presión y lo que
tenemos es un montón de granitos de
tierra o de piedritas y vamos a remover
las poco a poco y al ir removiendo los
granitos nuestro pistón o nuestro techo
movedizo se va a mover hacia arriba
porque pierde la presión de estos
granitos y por el contrario el gas sigue
ejerciendo una presión hacia arriba ok
entonces los gases siguen chocando con
los muros y al ir quitando los granitos
de forma que son infinitamente pequeño
si lo hacemos súper lento entonces
siempre vamos a estar cerca del
equilibrio nos vamos a mover de este
punto a este otro y más aún vamos a ver
que para que es como el primer estado de
nuestro ciclo de carne
siempre que pongamos este sistema encima
de un depósito de calor ok vamos a poner
este este depósito o esta reserva del
calor que está a temperatura de 1 y lo
que hace es mantener la temperatura
constante y así movernos de entre estos
dos puntos a lo largo de una curva
isoterma porque normalmente si
permitimos que esto ocurra de forma
diabética perdemos temperatura perdemos
energía cinética verdad en este caso
tenemos este depósito o esta reserva de
calor así que el calor va a ser
transferido al sistema ok déjenme
llamarlo q r de la reserva digamos si la
reserva o el depósito no estuviera aquí
la temperatura baja pero como tenemos
esta reserva vamos a constantemente
transferir calor y ya hemos visto esto
este solo a la primera fase del ciclo de
carnota nos movemos a lo largo de esta
curva isoterma
y la única razón por la cual puedo
dibujar cada uno de estos puntos es
porque este es cuasi estático siempre
son infinitamente cerca al equilibrio y
cuando digo reversible es porque no hay
fricción entre él entre el pistón y el
cilindro si quitamos un granito y lo
devolvemos tenemos exactamente el mismo
punto original ok eso es lo que me está
dibujando esta gráfica ahora cuál es la
gráfica de un proceso irreversible en
realidad no la voy a dibujar porque un
proceso irreversible va a ser digamos
más o menos similar a esto tenemos
nuestro nuestro gas ahí dentro ok pero
para fines del argumento déjenme poner
en vez de estos granitos voy a poner dos
piedras muy grandes ok y cuando remuevo
uno de estos grandes bloques voy de este
otro estado al otro pero obviamente todo
esto se rompe no estoy definiendo todas
mis macro variables entre los estados ok
entonces una vez que vaya de vuelta al
equilibrio si puedo definir el estado
pero en el proceso no
ok este es un proceso que nuestro mundo
se presenta y lo que vamos a tener es
fricción aquí este este pistón al
moverse puede generar calor por la
fricción ok
al chocar o al arrastrarse a lo largo de
los muros del cilindro en este caso en
el reversible curso r tenía que mantener
la temperatura y qué va a pasar con
curso déjenme llamarlo
el curso irreversible o curso y r ok que
tanto calor debe agregar para mantener
esto constante sabiendo que además se
pierde calor por él por la fricción
bueno este chico de aquí el pistón al
moverse está generando cierta fricción
su propio calor así que si fuera un
proceso a diabético no perdería mucha
temperatura como él como el otro así que
va a necesitar menos calor de la de la
reserva para mantener su temperatura a
tf1 alta así y mantenernos en estos
puntos del diagrama ok puede a lo mejor
moverse en una trayectoria muy loca de
hecho no podemos definir la trayectoria
en el proceso irreversible pero sabemos
que regresa a este punto segundo del
diagrama y cómo genera cierto calor por
la fricción esto va a necesitar menos
calor de la reserva así que déjenme
escribirlo
el calor absorbido por el proceso
reversible va a ser mayor que el calor
absorbido por el proceso irreversible y
eso es porque el proceso irreversible
está generando fricción
muy bien ahora cuál es el cambio la
entropía para ambos sistemas bueno ambos
empezaron aquí y terminaron en el otro
punto y la entropía es una variable de
estado así que el cambio la entropía
para el proceso reversible es es igual
va a ser igual al cambio la entropía
para el proceso irreversible ok para el
proceso irreversible y esto es porque la
entropía es una variable de estado ambos
van de los mismos puntos a los mismos
puntos y obviamente la entropía ha
cambiado ha cambiado porque nos hemos
movido de un estado a otro y la entropía
bueno no no voy a adentrarme mucho en
eso pero vamos a preguntar otra cosa
cuál es el cambio total de la entropía
del universo para el proceso reversible
así que el universo aquí va a ser va a
ser nuestro depósito y el sistema así
que déjenme escribirlo
no quiero que me quede sin espacio así
que para el proceso reversible digamos
el cambio en la entropía del universo va
a ser igual al cambio en la entropía del
proceso reversible más el cambio la
entropía de
lo que yo he usado de red déjenme
ponerle reservado de depósito como como
le puedo llamar desde el ambiente ok
vamos a llamarle del ambiente ok y el
proceso reversible el cambio la entropía
de este proceso es el calor agregado
aunque el calor ha agregado qr y usamos
esta definición porque es un proceso
reversible y hay que dividirlo entre t
uno que es la temperatura y cuál es el
cambio de la entropía de nuestro sistema
bueno está liberando q sub r verdad así
que está liberando así que hay que
ponerle un signo menos y dividirlo entre
la constante de la temperatura que esté
1 así que esto es igual a 0
es igual a 0 es bastante interesante de
hecho si tomo una nota aparte el cambio
la entropía del universo para un proceso
para un proceso reversible es cero y de
hecho esto debería ser bastante
intuitivo porque el punto aquí central
es que si vamos en una dirección podemos
siempre regresarnos así que si tenemos
si es cerca al equilibrio entonces la
entropía no debe ser tan grande de hecho
no debe cambiar así que podría como el
cambio la entropía es cero esto nos
permite que podamos regresar a lo largo
de esta trayectoria verdad el camión en
la entropía del universo es cero en este
caso
vamos a ver si podemos relacionar esto a
los procesos irreversibles si yo
quisiera determinar cuál es el cambio la
entropía de este proceso irreversible ok
el cambio la entropía del proceso
irreversible
déjenme restarle de aquí el calor el
calor que fue tomado del depósito ok de
la reserva q sub y r ok y todo esto
sobre t 1 que es que va a hacer esto en
relación al proceso anterior pero aquí
tenemos un proceso irreversible y
también espontáneo ok este valor vamos a
empezar en este punto así que el cambio
en la entropía del sistema simplemente
va a ser el mismo que el del proceso
reversible ya que es una variable de
estado y como dijimos no depende de lo
que hagamos simplemente de los puntos en
donde estamos ahora bien estamos tomando
menos calor que en el caso anterior así
que si escribiera éstos dejen déjenme en
limpiar esto
y r es el calor que absorbemos del
depósito ok pero es menor que el del
proceso reversible así que este número
de aquí es menor que el de este acá
arriba o podrías verlo de esta forma que
este número va a ser igual
o bueno que el canela entropía van a ser
iguales pero estoy quitando menos así
que va a ser mayor que 0 ok esto es para
el proceso irreversible
o que también es espontáneo
un proceso espontáneo
muy bien ahora vamos a hacer un poquito
de matemáticas aquí así que este es el
calor que esencialmente le fue cedido al
sistema irreversible es un menos porque
porque está siendo quitado de la reserva
o del depósito así que déjenme déjenme
multiplicar esto a ambos lados de la
ecuación por t 1 y vamos a tener t 1 por
delta s para el sistema irreversible
menos q y r para el sistema irreversible
y esto es mayor que 0 ahora vamos a qué
es esto
ok que es esta fórmula que podemos decir
bueno vamos a multiplicar ambos lados de
esta ecuación x menos 1 y recordemos que
esto es cierto para cualquier proceso
irreversible y espontáneo entonces al
multiplicar por menos 1 el calor
agregado al sistema irreversible menos
la temperatura por el cambio en la
entropía de este mismo sistema va a ser
menor que cero y esto es cierto para
cualquier proceso irreversible y es pont
y en este punto esto debería parecer
bastante familiar para ti porque cuando
escribimos la fórmula de la energía
libre de gips teníamos cambio en el
delta que es delta h - t por delta s y
dijimos que esto es menor que cero
cuando tenemos un proceso espontáneo
pero y esto todo tiene sentido porque
cuando tenemos esta equivalencia cuál es
la única diferencia aquí que escribimos
el calor en vez de delta h verdad y
hemos hecho esto ya a través de tres o
cuatro vídeos que el cambio en la
entalpía es igual al calor agregado al
sistema siempre y cuando tan tenemos un
sistema con presión constante ok
así que este resultado este es para
cualquier sistema irreversible y
espontáneo cualquiera cumple esto y si
suponemos que estamos trabajando con un
sistema de presión constante en realidad
esto se traduce al cambio mental para
menos de delta s ok esto de aquí debe
ser menor que cero y de hecho esa es la
fórmula de la del cambio la energía de
libre de jeeps va déjenme tocar un punto
más esto puede que puede encontrarse con
la idea de la segunda ley de la
termodinámica que nos dice que para
cualquier proceso espontáneo ok
su cambio en la entropía va a ser mayor
que cero bueno puede ser mayor o igual
que cero pero ya demostramos que es
estrictamente mayor verdad porque aunque
ésta no es la definición formal de
entropía bueno no estamos trabajando con
con un proceso reversible aquí pero
bueno puedes pensarlo de esta forma y
así al menos tener un nivel intuitivo de
lo que es la delta s para los procesos
irreversibles no va a fijarme mucho más
en esto esto es mucho más riguroso de lo
que hemos hecho hasta ahora así que
espero que esto tenga sentido y que
puedas
entender muy bien de dónde sale la
fórmula de la energía libre de gips para
reacciones en donde básicamente estamos
definiendo entre procesos reversibles e
irreversibles
ok relacionamos el calor y la entalpía